Die explosion am himmel war unnatürlich hell und gibt astronomie teams weltweit rätsel auf zwei teleskope des atlas projekts auf hawaii
hatten das mysteriöse objekt entdeckt mittlerweile wurde es von mindestens
24 teleskopen genauer untersucht und die fachwelt ist in aufregung denn so etwas habe man noch nie im
universum gesehen einen namen hat das objekt allerdings schon wird
alles was er noch zu dem mysteriösen phänomenen wissen müsst jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die explosion am 17 juni
2018 war ein ganz besonderes phänomen wie kate major eine mitarbeiterin des atlas projekts berichtet
die explosion ist wirklich wie aus dem nichts aufgetaucht
entdeckt wurde sie von zwei teleskope auf hawaii schnell musste ein name her und den bekam das objekt dann einfach durch die zufällige
zuweisung von buchstaben
cabrio oder abgekürzt ebene kaum noch immer ist nicht klar wobei sich bei der explosion gehandelt hat fest steht
das objekt zeigte sich extrem hell etwa zehn bis 100 mal heller als eine
supernova wie wir sie kennen deswegen gegen die forschungsteams auch zuerst davon aus dass es aus unserer
galaxie stammt mittlerweile wurde diese angabe korrigiert vermutlich stammt das objekt aus einer galaxie die 200 millionen lichtjahre
entfernt ist ihr name
cg cg
100 service
ethics and schon bald richteten sich nicht nur zwei sondern mindestens
24 teleskope weltweit auf das phänomen am himmel mittlerweile weiß waren das die explosion nicht nur besonders hell sondern auch besonders schnell war die
energiereichen teilchen schossen mit etwa 20.000 km pro sekunde nach außen ihr
oberflächentemperatur schätzen forschungsteams auf bis zu 9000 grad celsius
und es geht weiter mit äußerst ungewöhnlichen messwerten denn die beobachtung zeigten dass die explosion tatsächlich auf allen teilen des
elektromagnetischen spektrums
besonders selber von der röntgenstrahlung
angefangen bis zu den radiowellen in nur wenigen tagen
hatte weg ihre stärkste helligkeit erreicht ein großer unterschied zu den
supernovae wie wir sie kennen denn diese brauchen dazu meist mehrere wochen eine vermutung ist nun dass es eine
supernova gewesen sein könnte und zwar vom typ 1 c das bedeutet dass in einem riesigen stern der kern
zusammengebrochen ist und seine äußere hülle jung und wasserstoff verloren hat doch wie kam es dazu normalerweise
ist der radioaktive zerfall von nickel dafür
verantwortlich doch die
beobachtete explosion war dafür deutlich zu schnell und zu hell
und viel mehr details sie gibt es immer noch nicht die explosion gibt weiter rätsel auf zitat
etwas vergleichbares habe ich noch nie gesehen es muss sich um ein sehr seltenes objekt
handeln das sagt beispielsweise der irische astrophysiker stephen
smart in einem interview mit der washington post das große rätselraten um vi cao
derzeit verdeutliche unser nicht wissen im bereich der astronomie und physik
weitere messungen und analysen sind jetzt aber in planung und werden uns bald vielleicht mehr zu wirkt verraten doch selbst die forschungsteams
selbst sehen das erst in einigen monaten
wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollte dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die etwas
unkalkulierbare abo box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video game awards
erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken und
auf keinen fall die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
wird ein gamma blitz die erde zerstören der hellste blitz aller zeiten bis dann
bleibt dran